maybe me me me me me wawk wawk wawk wawk
wawk it ain't over until the fat lady
sings
and she's busting out of that [__]
limo right now as we speak I'm saying
it's the Lord's Day [__] whether you
wanted a nut
oh yeah that's the way to start off a
[__] Sunday you understand me
no [__] around everybody's in place
Jesus knows where he stands
oh [__]
[Music]
oh [__] you wanted it it's the Lord's
Day mother [__] uncle Joey's got and
forget about you
I've been busy [__] you
understand me trying to push it together
announcement is coming soon you know I'm
saying the thing you guys were waiting
for so I'm trying to put all that [__]
together but we're here for starters
happy Mother's Day to all the mothers
out there I don't have a mother but if I
did I'd be at a [__] side till they
giving a chump that's rubbing her feet
Tama lies I'm taking over the world and
[__] because I do miss my mother till
this day it's gonna be the 40th year
next year anniversary and it's like
eating food with no salt on it
so that's how I always felt it by the
ballet happy Mother's Day to you and
your families don't forget to go over to
bring them something don't be a [__]
cheapskate you [__] and if you
haven't spoken to her why just give her
a call tell her mom whatever happen
happen [__] I'm not [__] people
and uh bathrooms at the train station no
more I've changed you know I'm saying
anyway I got some tremendous [__]
Rufus for you we got this [__]
Skywalker we go when it comes in a black
container that means take on your own
[__] you know I'm saying they don't
put a warning on and we got some of this
dough seed doll from sunset herb we're
always throwing [__] he telling you a
[__] about the laws they're selling weed
that makes you [__] dizzy you
understand me
and that's it and that's that it's a
[__] Sunday you got the whole weekend
22 push-ups you got to write your goals
whatever happen last week who gives a
[__] who gives a [__] that's what we're
about [__] up and getting strong on a
daily but hey what am i Antony [__]
Robin Z let's smoke some [__] reef
and get the party started
the lungs are tip-top Magoo I did a
physical this way that the finger up the
ass I got blood drawn I did everything
I'm ready [__] I'll see you
[__] Providence Thursday night
to show sold out then Jersey four
[__] shows in a row then it's over
for the East Coast tour for right now we
come back we do a couple things then
June 4th we do a big thing here I'm
saying and then after that the [__]
tour starts to get in August I'm coming
to your [__] town it's gonna be all
over reefer [__] rose mcgowan giving
out coke the whole [__] deal you
understand me
but talk is cheap [__] let's do another
one you know I'm saying it's [__]
Sunday I didn't get you how to bed the
[__] well the state of the economy
and you know the chip Trump [__] took a
pea who gives a [__] who gives a [__]
with those creepy [__] people that
whole thing is [__] disgusting who
gives a flip I'd was worried about you
man
[__] the nose [__] it's all [__]
anyway it's all about you when you wake
up in the morning who's there with you
you who [__] has to get up and wash
his own ass on would you well you know
I'm saying so knock it off because I'm
so political Congress voted down go [__]
yourself it's all the [__] scam if
you didn't know that you'll find that
but it'll be a two-way cuz you'll be in
the [__] casket at the end it didn't
[__] matter all that matters is you
your family and the people around you
now you're gonna put it together 7:24 on
a daily you know I'm saying and who's
ever get in your way of you putting it
together 724 they gotta go they gotta go
you gotta go Joe you gotta go [__]
you see me dog
I travel [__] light I got my little
[__] [__] I got my dog re I
got my dog [__] Brogan I keep a man I
even ever get rid of some more kisses a
death out of my life well because you
don't need you don't need these energies
around you who gives a [__] I don't
believe in positive he's negative
well he's positive listen if somebody's
delivering the goods are delivered
because if they're not get the [__] out
of here if you hang out with enough
[__] losers you become a loser after
one get your [__] together it's [__]
the Lord's Day you could start all over
again today [__] a little bit
of weed write down your goals and let me
know what you want to do yourself the
next week that's it just the next week
and I guarantee next Friday you'll be
gonna look at me get my dick sucked by a
chick that don't speak English I'm
saying anyway that's it and that's that
may 26 I'm going a little workout in
preparation you know the time at the ice
house that's gonna be the final result
man some [__] killers and that's it
and that's that I just want to touch
base really you know I don't forget
about you the church tonight you'll have
a church tomorrow morning and you got a
church on Wednesday you know I'm saying
you know I deliver the goods I'm like
Judas Priest and the [__] help them
full other door
have I told you people I love smoking
marijuana I [__] love it I don't give
a [__] I don't need none else I need to
be at a bar talking ha ha ha ha oh my
god did you hear it but who gives a [__]
I need to be smoking right and getting
ready for you [__] you
understand me also a shout-out to my
girl
Mackenzie done with that [__] savage
[__] muffler she went in there last
night and just hit the quick pop a big
pop that's it so she was 7 pounds
overweight what I never showed up the
[__] weight watch the 7 pounds
overweight no big deal you do it to [__]
you gotta do your exam and I said that's
that if you think I'm here to take your
whole thing no I just wanted to check in
with you [__] make sure you're
solid make sure you know uncle Joey
loves you make sure we got the two
podcasts coming I'll see you
[__] in Providence bring the
motel and the [__] cheese with the
persuit bring them what listen tell me
improv this bring me a [__] nice
sandwich I want a mucho hell would
presume some roasted peppers I don't ask
for much and I'm saying you know I'm
over here killing myself on Weight
Watchers when whatnot I don't ask for
much
and that's it and that's that I keep it
simple you don't leave my [__] around
there's no hope lying I've no posse
honey nobody I smoked reefer I sprinkle
a little THC dust in my head and I'm
like a [__] magician on a solo trip
this beautiful this as simple as it gets
because I'm gonna the farmers market for
figs suck my dick eat an apple the [__]
is wrong with you remember there's a
kiss of death and he'll - kick him to
the side who gives a [__] you hang out
with enough of these [__] people you
become one of them that's what you want
to be pick four [__] people take a
look at them take a look at whether they
doing what are they doing right each of
them have something to offer you put it
together make your own a little
jambalaya and watch for the [__]
result you understand me I got left back
on the seventh grade I had a GED I'm
living like a doctor over here I don't
give a [__] you understand me I'm out to
show up the body's like the kiss
nobody's ass I live on my own [__]
terms I'm like so not sure I did it my
[__] way and you could if I could do
it imagine what you could do you got a
mother you got a father you got
resources go out there stop being a
[__] [__] wake up grab your [__]
balls and say today's the day somebody's
swallowing this [__] nut juice
whether they'd like you to [__] not
understand me I'm not even taking my
dick huh I'm doing it through osmosis 20
years ago I didn't what I'm doing now I
had to do with a gun I'm doing it to you
mentally you understand me because
number comes a mental [__] game you
see the whole [__] field but to see
the whole field you gotta [__] make
yourself better every week like a
[__] Savage that you are I don't give
a [__] okay one of grandmas volumes get
the notebook out write your goals and
get ready for the best [__] week in
your life
because the numbers not where you start
it's where you finish I'm saying anyway
I am [__] up but that's what happens
sometimes you gotta be professional and
you gotta take a bullet for the universe
you understand me and that's what I did
today don't forget to podcast this week
too I'm always with you [__]
you might not think I'm watching you or
I'll sit on the salad look at me I look
like all those [__] dogs and surely
one of those [__] dogs that come up
to you and you just when you get lost up
in the mountains really a Saint Bernard
but the [__] I'm getting older by the
day I don't give a [__] no I'm getting
old I'm getting [__] better I'm
swinging dick with three [__] hands
you understand me so get ready to rock
and tell'em alt I didn't get my metal
happy nah look at that rock Lonnie Raya
okay literally who we are saying that's
the way it is you understand me so get
it together today it's Sunday it's all
right cooking mama hug tell her you love
we're all hard
you have no idea what it's like to live
like without a mother especially for
years as well you know tell the rest of
these [__] jerk-offs get it together
cook your mom a kiss grab her back and
tell her mom
you're a [__] Savage you spit me out
of that [__] monkey and you [__]
made me into a man or a woman that I
have that's it it's that easy no drama
no Rosie I have everybody wants to be a
[__] half of [__] hallmark [__] all
that [__] if I had a mother I'd be over
there today rubbing her feet cut her
toenails and eat them here I'm saying
but that's the way it is listen have a
great week we'll see you tonight we'll
see you Wednesday Providence I'm ready
for you [__] Guinea [__]
we're gonna rock the house and then
Jersey Friday and Saturday you have no
[__] idea
to be going home Jack remember I left
there with a warrant now I'm back [__]
headlining at Vinny's [__] stress
factory right so get back this is your
week [__] don't let nobody [__]
with you if they do tell him uncle Joey
sent you you ain't taking that [__]
[__] no more I love you have a great
[__] week have a great Mother's Day
and that's it and that's bad stay black